what I want to do is explain before we
get into this topic the way that we're
going to approach this probably at least
the way it fits in my brain okay
I'm gonna do that by way of a linguistic
metaphor okay now I just want you to its
silent Lee I want you to look at these
four letters there are suffix right or
there usually a suffix the way you end a
word sometimes they're in the middle of
a word but we'll get to that and here's
what I want you to do again slightly I
want you to look at it on your reader
and then on the count of three I'm gonna
ask all of you to say these four letters
aloud okay and I'm not gonna give you
any more information
it's very deliberate okay so count of
three four letters you're gonna read
them out loud
ready one two three okay so I wonder if
I wonder if you heard your well you
obviously knew what your answer was but
if you heard the answers of the people
beside you and noticed well that was a
trick question
wasn't it you can see I have these six
numbers underneath there because there's
many ways to pronounce these four
letters right can someone give me one
one of them said again ooh okay so for
example in the word hmm
you can say those four letters like an O
sound okay so I'll give you another one
because you don't say though okay so T
yeah though so it's like it's just an H
sound Oh give me another one ah what
tough okay thank you
tough I've putting that one first for a
reason okay I've got three more cough
cough cough yeah okay yeah sure I maybe
I have seven okay I think I'm gonna
check that I'll check it here see how we
go okay I missing at least two more
possibly three come on think think think
think
sayin doh thank you
as in don't I suppose so yes sure
tough through though no it's not that
one no that's the same one isn't it the
same one right though and oh yeah
they're the same one okay that was a
miss miss copy can we give another one I
have to consult my list because they
even I can't remember like
let's see hmm when you have oh yeah yeah
when you have a thing that comes into
your brain it's called ah a thought so
that one's sneaky because it's not a
suffix it's got a T on the end if you do
something you know sort of not
carelessly but paying close attention
and going in the details you'd call that
Sahra thank you and it's true I think I
do have I think I do have seven this
one's really really where that rare
though it's like I said pretty rare does
anyone know what one of these is Slough
Slough it's like a it's like a you can
have a slouch like a muddy kind of like
gross thing you want to weigh in too
it's terrible
okay now yes it is I think it's named
because anyway alright so I put I put
this one first because it's the first
one children when they're learning to
read when they learn about and they're
sounding things that's called phonics
right and when I don't know if you guys
remember remember when you were really
little like kindergarten a new one that
kind of thing you had readers do
remember readers like little little
books very very thin and they use the
same words over and over again like
Tovar went to go buy some milk and then
on the next page is like till I went to
good buy some bread so they get to
practice a whole series of words very
quickly so this first word here kids
learn about and then these words here
they're all not told for a very
deliberate reason can anyone guess why
readers deliberately avoid saying those
words or writing those words any thought
because it's specific confusing
look I deliberately put these in an
order right one two three four five
words up the top here they differ by
like what a couple of letters each
that's like maddeningly confusing right
so we deliberately restrict things and
we say look there we know there's a big
universe out there other stuff but we're
only going to keep them in this little
box so you don't get confused okay and
that's kind of what we've been doing
with this topic you can make a heading
now think about this for a second when
you very very for the first time in year
9 we're introduced to this topic what
was it about it was about triangles
right as that triangles specifically it
was about angles and sides in triangles
and how they relate right and you can
even see it there in the word try going
there you go triangles right you're
measuring those things okay but then in
over the last few years we've been
gradually expanding on that right we've
been saying what else is trigonometry
about it's not just about right-angled
triangles for instance what other kinds
of triangles is about equilateral
triangles scalene
it's about all triangles in fact and
then we said actually it's not even just
about triangles or it you think back
more recently now right maybe want to
draw one of these on your page you drawn
of these just a small one right what
does she know which we have to do with
something like this hmm
we redefine oh yeah okay so you could
think about it as the quadrants the
coordinates diagram all stations is
central where we're getting ahead of
cells a little bit before that we said
let's redefine everything you know about
trigonometry all this sine cos tan
business by the way what do they stand
for sine itself that's an abbreviation
of what well that's a bit of a cheat
signs of radiation for sine cos that's a
proper abbreviation its abbreviation of
cosine thank you and tan is short for
tangent does anyone know why that is you
want to know why you don't know it's
because of this it's because of this we
can tell you I'm very happy to tell you
right now if you like but it's because
of this we don't want to like blow your
brains apart okay so we took all these
things which we used to think of in
right-angled triangles and we said no no
no no they are actually a different kind
of object again it's one that sits on
this does anyone remember it has a
special name starts with a you actually
two words kind of cheating it's this guy
what's this guy again this is the unit
circle right so we said if you got one
one minus one minus one what do sine and
cos have to do with this
unit circle have a think do you remember
okay look actually let me wind back even
if you don't actually remember the
actual art are does anyone remember this
actually happening the unit circle had
something to do a trick yep that's okay
alright so most of you have a vague
memory there let me remind you okay stop
me at the point when you're like honored
and I can fill this in okay so pick a
point others in fact I'd love you to
label a point any point on the
circumference your radius they don't
want to stop me yet can you unfill me in
I'm gonna throw an angle here fader can
anyone stop me yet
okay so I we are going to connect arcs
in a second but not quite yet this is
like earlier on right can anyone stop me
yet have a think everything so what we
did was we completely redefined the
trigonometric ratios we said actually
forget thinking about triangles we said
on the unit circle if you start from the
positive x-axis this right hand side
right and you measure around some angle
any angle you like if this looks like I
don't know sixty degrees or something
but you could keep going further you can
make an obtuse angle a reflex angle etc
then cause is the x coordinate of that
point on the circumference you get to
and what's the Y Quinn it just just have
a guess you've only got two options you
have 50/50
it's sine thank you and it's
alphabetical which is nice okay so
here's what we did we took that okay and
then we recognized if you take that
cause that side we can now graph all of
these things and this is we really where
we're going to pick up in terms of our
review so I told you you'd need a ruler
the first thing was to draw this set of
axes but the next thing is to draw free
please three sets of axes beneath that
and I would advise that whatever a
remaining amount of space on the page
you have divide that into three and
we're going to use the whole page for
these three graphs okay
okay so we'll start with saya now as you
do that I'm just gonna even though
you're sure these still drawing a few of
those axes I'm just gonna ask you to
with your free like non writing hand
just put a finger up in the air and
trace out for me we'll start with sign
can you trace out me from left to right
what does the sign curve what does it
look like you trace out for me with your
finger yeah yeah it goes this goes up
comes down and then sort of like stops I
mean it keeps going but we don't need to
do it forever right okay so you can keep
on going back to that but let's let's
draw that okay so hopefully what you
trace that roughly we're something like
this like so okay that should have been
I asked almost have you got that I'm
gonna end that right there okay someone
tell me something anything that they
know about this graph apart from its
shape yeah go ahead it's positive from
zero so here's zero when you say
positive what do you mean it's going up
so you're talking about the gradient of
that right that's going up right
positive gradient where does it stop
being positive by the way at the at the
drop yeah but at the crest okay so we
got it yeah all right so at this crest
here um we have named Suzy wave language
is what what do we call this kind of
point
oh station it's sort of like stops there
and then it comes down Oh what is that
value by the way that value right there
at what x value would that happen I am
going to take one but it's not the x
value one's the ones the height isn't it
up here okay that's how tall you can go
and we've got another name for that by
the way how far away you can go it
starts with an a half I can go away it's
the amplitude right so this distance
here is the amplitude I'll write that in
we still haven't got an x value for that
like how far to the right do I have to
travel to get to that point so you know
one no the x value okay so let's hit
pause for a moment
okay let's support remember pens down
for a second just look back over here
look back at these words okay actually
want you to carefully look at the list
of words right
do you feel comfortable that when you
look at that list of words you don't
have to like consult a pronunciation
guide or anything like that you know how
to pronounce all it may be except for
the last one that's a weird word but are
you okay with all of those ones like I
can I'm not even thinking you just kind
of instantly hear the word in your mind
right we call that fluency in language
right mathematics has fluency as well we
need to know that this x value here is
exactly ninety degrees you've got to be
able to say that to me instantly okay
because it's a whole lot of other number
of fact and geometric facts we're going
to have to call on so that's something
which you're like I didn't I didn't have
that and just judging by the response it
felt like none of us did
okay and this means that we've got a lot
of review on this area cuz this is we
haven't carrying anything new yet okay
all right 90 degrees degrees the only
unit that we can use to describe what's
going on here they're not right I could
also call this in radians I could call
it PI on two very good so I'm gonna use
what's gonna be another one I don't use
another color here and if you have
another color I'd encourage you to do
the same I'm gonna put PI on two
underneath that so make sure when you
write 90 that's a 90 degrees and then
we're also saying that's pound two